[Music]
we're on the set of your video for lala
land I'm obsessed with a song by the way
so good known each other we was gonna
get to that should we start with that
yeah I've known this guy for 10 years 15
years yeah about 15 years her little
brother is my best we talked about this
moment many times that we were gonna be
doing an interview I'm a little
emotional it's exciting hey baby waste
your time with me in California
tell me about the concept for this video
we basically put LA inside of a box
figuratively and literally just like all
the classic stereotypes of like
Hollywood living and culture we just
kind of condensed into a soundstage
pretty darling let go got time but you
got go talk about the love interest in
this Melanie Iglesias and she kind of is
the opposite of the Hollywood chick okay
which is fantastic like that's what I
wanted she she's like worked her way up
she's funny she's cute she's witty she
still gets awkward like she's a real
person do you get a say in the casting
yeah you chose her oh yeah how involved
are you in actual creative process why
don't we say too much I'm aware that I'm
not that I don't know everything in
every detail but I pay attention to a
lot of details so I like things to look
a certain way and I have like an idea of
what I want my whole thing to be what's
gonna happen in this beautiful cosmic
red car behind us oh this we didn't
realize this was bad
so me and yg are gonna be sitting in
that car yeah rapping and writing about
California
[Music]
how'd you get yg on this song I mean
that's huge I was honestly shocked like
he was my first pick for like months we
were trying to get him I think and then
he finally heard the song and he was
like yeah this song I feel like is gonna
be epic but Drew Barrymore was so big
already why was this the right song to
follow that up I think drew barrymore
work because it's fun to sing and girls
want to be that girl that you're talking
about it's kind of the same thing with
this who doesn't want to be swept off
their feet and taking the California I
mean like it's just it kind of completes
the whole postcard image of wow this
lifestyle that people are so intrigued
by how has your life changed since
releasing drew Barrymore diamonds to
dust it's so different this is way
better now I mean I was unsigned when I
put out drew Barrymore on Spotify and
then found the right label and the right
team and started building we're on the
second video shoe you know now it's like
it's getting good you know the album
coming out when is that coming out to
have a date yet I don't have a date it's
this summer for sure you are on tour I
mean your life has gotten so big how are
you staying grounded and what is your
mom Queen Traci what does she think
about this she would be here right now
but she's sick I have my parents voices
in my head like all the time
so that helps but also I mean like like
my best friends are partly involved in
this you know they they've been able to
tell me when I'm acting like an O for a
long time now and they're not going to
stop all of a sudden I can attest to
this by the way my mom will also call
them out but your you remember a jerk
Everett
when you think about the type of career
that you do want to have what does that
look like so funny because like a year
ago it would have been to this point you
know what I mean like I just that I want
my music to reach as many people would
help as many people as possible and like
be able to take care of the people that
I love man that'd be good are you coming
for that Best New Artist Grammy next
year sure yeah have you thought about
that it would be cool I don't want to
pretend like it wouldn't be cool like if
it happened I would be flipping out yeah
I wouldn't I would lose my cool they'd
have to play me off the stage
hey baby waste your time with me and
California